hello everyone and welcome to today's
contestants are Kelsey Dalton and Sheila
do you guys think that you're pretty
knowledgeable in celebrity products and
stuff
sure whoa that doesn't sound very I know
Kylie of lift kits and I watch TMZ and E
news all the time so I'm pretty
confident is there a price
there's the pride that you know all the
answers
we're gonna take are you ready yeah all
right so bring the first product over
where are we going Huggies is a puffy
pillow pillow puppies it's a dog toy if
this Samuel docker created by one Ellen
DeGeneres to Jimmy Fallon or three
Martha Stewart Jimmy Fallon my pastor
incorrect no no Ellen DeGeneres
are you guys ready for the second
product I guess okay bring it in oh boy
oh this like I feel so cool damn you
look dope you guys probably know the
answer but is it a Katy Perry be Ariana
Grande every Meghan Trainor it's Ariana
Grande that's correct
are you guys ready for the next one yeah
all right bring it in Oh orange egg
Gweneth Paltrow be Jessica Alba or see
Halle Berry
that was me 100,000% what's your caliber
that's correct I think we can use it no
thank you
Vaseline like what's the difference okay
all righty next product is Michael
Strahan be brand Seacrest or see David
Beckham can we get your hands oh the
noise that's part of the game okay David
mom okay can I ask ahead no that wasn't
part of the room come on Dalton just
give it no
bring the last product over [ __ ] but
let's see smell no of course it's not
hey the host is this perfume from a to
Beyonce be Jennifer Lopez or see Rihanna
that was Kelsey oh my gosh Kelsey you
killed it today Dalton how do you feel
about not winning not good do you want
this shirt I'm not gonna wear it
oh it's not my size I'm too fast sure
you gotta have fun okay fine I feel like
the real winner here I got Ariane a
headphone what can I keep though I'm the
host we're gonna have pride is there a
prize the pride the pride the pride that
you know all the answers alright guys
well that is it congratulations to
Kelsey we'll see you next time on next
time on
meow
[Music]